bonsoir le journal de la rédaction
nouvelle édition ce 30 septembre le tour
de l'actualité locale comme chaque soir
en direct à 18 heures et dans
l'actualité une forte mobilisation
nationale des pharmaciens aujourd'hui
ils contestent la réforme des
professions réglementées
on ne comptait qu'une quinzaine
d'officine ouvertes dans les yvelines
smarties l'état redéfinisse et zones
géographiques prioritaires des zones
pour lesquelles des moyens
supplémentaires sont à louer un
redécoupage qui agace le maire
communiste de la verrière nous verrons
les conséquences pour sa ville
invité thierry cazes directeur du
développement économique de la
communauté d'agglomération de saint
quentin avec lui nous parlerons de
l'immobilier d'entreprise à saint
quentin en yvelines le territoire est il
toujours attractif de nombreuses
personnalités de la boxe française et
saint-quentinoise ont tenu à lui rendre
hommage une dernière fois ce matin les
obsèques d'antoine farrugia avait lieu à
l'église saint médard à elancourt
l'entraîneur emblématique du boxing club
d'elancourt 50 ans s'est éteint mardi
dernier et des suites d'un long combat
face à troyes cancer antoine farrugia
avait 70 ans les pharmaciens se
mobilisent contre le projet de réforme
du gouvernement et ils descendent dans
la rue la majorité des officines du
département je vous le disais ont suivi
ce mouvement de grève national ils sont
restés portes closes
rencontre avec quelques blouse blanche
avant leur départ pour paris ce matin et
yolaine thorez patrick jacques de
dixmude rideaux fermés et affiches
placardées sur les vitrines ce mardi
environ 95 pour cent des pharmaciens
yvelinois ont suivi le mouvement de
grève national à la gare de montigny le
bretonneux ce matin quelques blouses
blanches ont pris la direction de paris
avec leurs collègues ils sont descendus
dans la rue pour protester contre deux
mesures projet du gouvernement
la première autorisé la vente de
médicaments accessibles sans ordonnance
dans les grandes surfaces
ça peut engendrer
des personnes qui savent pas comment
utiliser le doliprane par exemple parce
que ça peut être dangereux
ils peuvent pas poser de question donc
viivent on l'utilisait comme des voix et
voilà pareil pour le reste il vu
profanes ou s'ils ont un rhume et savent
pas savoir s'ils ont une toux grasse une
toux sèche
voilà tout est question que nous on peut
répondre
du côté des consommateurs les avis sont
partagés je préfère aller en pharmacie
moi parce qu'il apporte des conseils et
je préfère voir enfin des vrais
professionnels
je fais quand même confiance au magasin
aux pharmaciens qui est un conseil quand
même non non je sauf les trucs
par exemple de l'aspirine joly prend les
choses comme ça si le marché supermarché
est équipé d'un phare martial je ne vois
pas de différence faut limiter vos
limité par le nombre de pharmacies mais
nombre de médicaments avant nous lasser
tout autre réforme voulue par le
gouvernement ouvrir le capital des
officines à des actionnaires non
pharmaciens une réforme qui l'a aussi
soulève l'inquiétude des professionnels
les investisseurs forcément seraient
investis dans des grandes régions mais
en fait on aurait une déperdition des
pharmacies en zone rurale et du coup ce
serait catastrophique pour justement le
service de santé publique m
résultat des pharmacies pourraient bien
voir leur porte close cette fois ci
définitivement 4000 seraient menacés
faire une structure immédiate et donc à
travers ses 4000 pharmacies ses quatre
mille chômeurs et d'autres suivraient
forcément puisque après après en fait on
pourrait pas on ne pourrait pas
continuer d'exister en ce jour de grève
nationale de l'agencé régionale de santé
d'ile-de-france avaient tous le même
réquisitionné 15 officines dans les
yvelines et les formations n'étaient pas
les seuls mobilisé on ce mardi les
professions libérales dans leur ensemble
étaient dans la rue et médecins fermiers
huissiers notaires avocats greffiers des
tribunaux de commerce architecte
géomètre et autres professionnels du
logement sous la même bannière
revendications communes ne pas toucher
au secteur réglementé pour les notaires
on retiendra également qu'ils veulent
conserver leurs tarifs pour portionné
l'eau montant des transactions
immobilières qu'il refuse la
libéralisation des conditions
d'installation et qu'ils veulent
conserver le monopole sur la rédaction
et l'authentification des actes un
mouvement sans précédent le gouvernement
évoque des solutions concertées dans les
prochaines semaines que pensez-vous en
tout cas de cet important mouvement les
professions libérales ou telle raison de
se mobiliser
de tels d'une telle manière c'est notre
question du jour tout à fait parce que
c'est pas normal que leclerc par exemple
veut y vendre des médicaments et tout ça
il faut que les pharmacies reste des
pharmaciens quoi je crois que tout le
monde a le droit de se défendre dans la
vie et 6,6 pour garder leur pouvoir
d'achat pourquoi pauvres en france
apparemment ce qui marche bien c'est de
descendre dans la rue et puis débloqué
la marche aide de l'état
il aurait son faux pas comme c'est bien
gentil il ne demande pas d'augmentation
mais n'ont pas envie qu'on leur tape
dessus
si vous donnez surtout quand leur bus
qu'on leur retire des conditions de
travail je pense que s'ils ont des
choses effectivement à défendre et puis
notre sécurité aussi je pense que oui
c'est une bonne chose
je te les faire une prise de sang ce
matin j'ai pas pu directement le
gouvernement a dévoilé en juin dernier
sa nouvelle carte des quartiers
prioritaires ces zones qui bénéficient
des aides financières de l'état seront
réduites d'ici à 2015 parmi les perdants
les écarter du dispositif figure un
quartier à la verrière le quartier
orly-parc le maire a donc lancé une
pétition pour inverser cette tendance
yolaine thérèse elodie moi faisons que
la verrière reste une priorité de l'état
c'est devenu le leitmotiv de la commune
depuis plus de trente ans les quartiers
hlm du bois de l'étang et dans les parcs
bénéficient d'une aide financière de
l'état en tant que quartier prioritaire
mais dès 2015 le quartier dans les parcs
pourraient bien être écartés de ce
dispositif
plusieurs conséquences sont à prévoir
dont l'une des plus importantes
la baisse des effectifs d'enseignants
dans les classes aujourd'hui dans toutes
nos écoles de la ville nous avons des
effectifs à moins de 25 enfants par
classe donc il n'ya plus qu'au bon il
est temps que cette règle serait
appliquée mais sur les deux autres
groupes scolaires c'est à dire l'école
régionale et l'école du parc nous
retrouvrions des effectifs de 32 33
enfants actuellement un peu plus de 2400
quartiers sont en géographie dites
prioritaires dès 2015 il ne resterait
plus que 1300 en voulant se concentrer
sur les quartiers les plus pauvres
l'état a modifié ses critères et en a
retenu qu'un seul le revenu par habitant
inquiet le maire est allé plaider auprès
du gouvernement pour une prise en compte
des particularités de sa commune
il est vrai que le revenu moyen médian
du moins à orly parc est un peu
supérieure
nous avons expliqué à l'état que quand
on cumule les revenus des habitants du
parc et du bois de l'étang nous sommes
inférieures aux critères nous avons
expliqué qu'il faut prendre en compte la
dimension globale de notre ville en plus
nous sommes une toute petite ville tout
le monde se connaît tous le monde
fréquente les mêmes activités et donc la
l'échelle de la ville la dimension de la
ville compte beaucoup
le gouvernement devrait statuer au mois
d'octobre
en attendant les travaux continuent au
bois de l'étang par exemple ces espaces
de jeu refait il ya trois quatre ans
c'est 80 logements en cours de
réalisation ou encore la rénovation de
ce gymnase sont autant de projets rendus
possibles par le dispositif élus du
département communautés religieuses
étaient rassemblés ce lundi soir à
versailles pour soutenir les chrétiens
d'orient à l'invitation de la députée
ump yvelinoise valérie pécresse co
présidente du groupe d'études sur les
chrétiens d'orient un soutien qui
intervient le jour même de l'audition
par le groupe d'étude parlementaire de
laurent fabius ministre des affaires
étrangères catherine château et william
l une photo de famille sur les marches
de la mairie de versailles rassemblés ce
lundi soir des élus du département mais
aussi les membres de différentes
communautés religieuses pour apporter
leur soutien aux chrétiens d'orient
persécutés en irak et répondre à l'appel
de la députée évinoise valérie pécresse
qui souhaite dit elle faire un pont
humanitaire faire un appel humanitaire à
la solidarité des yvelinois cet appel
j'ai demandé à tous les parlementaires
du groupe sur les chrétiens d'orient que
j'anime à l'assemblée nationale de le
relayer dans leur département c'est à
dire qu'en fait c'est un appel yvelinois
mais il ya sans appel aujourd'hui qui
sont lancés dans tous les départements
de france l'idée c'est de collecter des
dons de les envoyer à des associations
qui ont pignon sur rue l'oeuvre d'orient
la croix rouge le secours catholique une
cellule d'accueil des chrétiens d'orient
a été mise en place au ministère des
affaires étrangères la députée espère
également que les élus feront des
propositions pour recevoir ces
populations actuellement en france une
centaine seraient présents elle valérie
pécresse a reçu dans son appel le
soutien des différentes communautés
religieuses catholiques protestantes
mais également musulmane et
il faut se souvenir que à evian 1938 à
une conférence internationale et que
parce que on prévoyait à peu près on
ressent télé les choses quelqu'un
qu'elle y arrive je crois comme
aujourd'hui en irak et au moyen-orient
aujourd'hui on les a entendus on a
entendu les chrétiens d'orient et toutes
les minorités et je crois que grâce à la
réunion grâce à madame pécresse est bien
coté peut-être que cette fois ci au
moins les choses se dérouleront mieux
le premier devoir dans la foi et la fois
dans le devoir à partir du moment où une
entité qu'elle se soit est menacé d
clair que par conviction et musulmans va
se déterminer
1 c'est l'éclairage de sa foi ce qui est
juste ce qui ce qui est bien et bien ce
qui est mal et mal nous devons dénoncer
le mal où l'injustice
là où elle est c'est un sujet qui nous
intéresse tous et qui nous concerne tous
parce que la liberté religieuse la
liberté tout simplement de vivre sur la
terre le pays 2 sur lequel on habite
depuis des millénaires
depuis des années peu importe cette
liberté fondamentale nous avons le
devoir et le désir de la sauvegarder
l'église catholique recevra d'ailleurs
le 23 novembre prochain en la cathédrale
saint-louis de versailles des chrétiens
d'orient pour écouter et partager leurs
témoignages
et puis juste un mot de politique pour
vous dire que cet après-midi gérard
larcher sénateur des yvelines a été
désigné candidat de l'ump pour la
présidence du sénat un poste qu'il avait
auparavant déjà occupé élections devant
l'ensemble des sénateurs ce sera demain
mercredi après midi nous allons parler
dans tout autre sujet à présent nous
allons parler immobilier d'entreprise un
secteur qui semble ne pas connaître la
crise si on en croit les chiffres près
de 13 milliards d'euros ont été investis
en immobilier d'entreprise en france sur
les huit premiers mois de l'année contre
8 sur la même période l'an dernier mon
sortira case vous êtes le directeur du
développement économique de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aujourd'hui
sur l'agglomération même constat que sur
le reste de la france
immobilier d'entreprise se porte plutôt
bien les entreprises investissent des
locaux les entreprises oui investissent
des locaux ce qui est important
effectivement ses devoirs
arrivée des entreprises l'indicateur
c'est l'arrivée des entreprises
l'arrivée des salariés pour ça faut être
sûr de le territoire puisse offrir des
locaux adaptés et permettent donc
l'accueil de ces entreprises c'est là
tout votre travail dont nous allons
parler déjà ce matin vous avez tenu une
conférence de presse pour faire un
premier bilan de ces derniers mois bill
par les ailes des grands projets
également pour l'agglomération on
regarde ce reportage ensemble de florane
parfait qui étaient présentes ce matin
et puis on parle juste après comme un
symbole de l'attractivité de
l'agglomération le bâtiment star center
à montigny le bretonneux siège social de
mercedes-benz depuis à peine un an avec
9300 établissements économiques et 3,8
millions de m² d'immobilier d'entreprise
le bilan du territoire est positif nous
avons vraiment développer des services
aux salariés
les restaurants d'entreprise les crèches
interentreprises les hôtels également
qui est une particularité importante
pour les entreprises si le parc
immobilier a subi la crise économique
l'agglomération de saint quentin a su
stabiliser sa croissance elle a atteint
en 2013 le palier du million de mètres
carrés après une forte diminution en
2009 depuis une dizaine d'années le
territoire mis sur la construction et la
restructuration c'est beaucoup par le
renouvellement immobilier donc
démolition reconstruction que l'offre
immobilière sur saint quentin va
continuer à être produite et bien sûr il
ya eu pour une part marginale de l'ordre
de 10 à 20% de l'immobilier neuf sur des
terrains aujourd'hui vierge disponible
mais cette cette offre sur l'immobilier
disponible encore non construit elle se
réduit puisque aujourd'hui le territoire
se se continuer à s'aménager se
restructurer de grands projets sont
prévus sur l'agglomération comme
l'extension du campus du crédit agricole
de 20 mille mètres carrés d'ici 2016
l'arrivée de l'entreprise s'affrontent
en quelques mois où les cinquante cinq
mille mètres carrés de bureaux neufs du
parc gardanne ouest dé paris d'envergure
mais calculé globalement saint quentin
est plutôt une zone dans lequel
il ya une adéquation qui est assez
réaliste entre les projets et la demande
donc on peut se dire que globalement il
n'y a pas de sur offre à craindre où il
n'y a pas de décalage important entre
l'offre et la demande y compris à
horizon 2030 avec vélizy le pôle de
saint quentin est celui qui a le mieux
résisté
les yvelines concentre 9 % du parc de
bureaux de l'île de france et thierry 15
invités donc du journal de ce mardi on
va reposer peut-être un petit peu les
bases aussi sur ce secteur l'immobilier
d'entreprise à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ça représente quoi on a entendu dans les
yvelines ça pèse 9 % du parc
oui ça représente surtout plus de cent
mille emplois et donc c'est de
l'immobilier qui permet d'accueillir des
entreprises industrielles et entreprises
de services un peu de logistique et des
entreprises qui sont dans dans le
service dans le tertiaire
donc c'est des bureaux des entreprises
l'activité du mixte c'est donc une un
territoire qui se développe et qui se
poursuit pour pouvoir accueillir des
entreprises de toutes sortes et toutes
natures et faire de saint quentin en
yvelines le deuxième pôle économique de
l'ouest parisien
c'est la torah bright mais on y
travaille c'est là tout l'enjeu est
resté un bon niveau d'accueil
c'est un pôle qui portait sur l'ensemble
du territoire saint quentinois ou est ce
qu'il ya des secteurs des villes montini
par exemple billancourt qui vampirisent
un peu l'attractivité dont ça se
développe on voit bien que les
entreprises sont à peu près sur
l'ensemble du territoire ont présenté ce
matin les quatre grands pôles
économiques du territoire
à l'ouest le paul ii qui se situe sur la
structuration du corridor ferroviaire le
pôle ce qui est l'université bien sûr le
plus gros le plus connu là où il ya plus
le plus d'entreprises mais il y aussi le
secteur est où il ya on retrouve le
technocentre renault et puis tout un tas
d'autres entreprises dans des parcs
d'affaires
donc c'est un territoire qui est
relativement équilibrée par alain plante
partout j'aurais fait commune on y
veille disons qu'on fait en sorte qu'il
y ait du développement immobilier adapté
à une demande il ya des entreprises qui
cherchent plus le parc d'affaires qui
cherche d'avoir avoir plus d'espacé ce
moment ça va être peut-être - près d'une
gare et donc de
de répondre l'enjeu c'est surtout de
répondre à ce que cherchent les
entreprises et à la demande des
entreprises
on peut aiguiller un petit peu et bien
sûr en aiguille un petit peu à travers
des projets d'aménagement mais l'enjeu
c'est surtout de répondre à ce que ce
que souhaitent les entreprises alors
papa de manière complètement débridé il
s'agit pas d'urbaniser des secteurs qui
sont pas l'organiser mais on est quand
même faut tout repenser les
infrastructures il faut tout penser
lorsqu'on pense à immobilier
d'entreprise bien sûr qu'on a un
territoire qui compte se construit
depuis depuis quarante ans maintenant
donc il ya déjà dédé grand des grands
enjeux qui sont posées en termes
d'infrastructures voirie de transport et
d'accès des différents sites immobiliers
tels qu'ils existent aujourd'hui vous
parler des demandes des entreprises
justement est ce que ces entreprises ont
des demandes différentes mais il ya 40
ans oui les entreprises ont évolué
puisque aujourd'hui les grands groupes
ne sont plus propriétaires de leurs
mobiliers donc ils sont ils sont dans du
locatif donc les propriétaires ce sont
des investisseurs institutionnels des
défauts et détruisent les assurances des
défauts des foncières qui attend des
rendements de leurs de leur immobilier
donc on a les propriétaires qui sont ces
grands fonds il ya les utilisateurs qui
sont les entreprises c'est ce que ceux
avec lesquels on travaille le plus c'est
ça qui est important est finie et puis
tous les conseils et les structures de
conseil qui accompagne les entreprises
pour les conseiller sur tel ou tel de
localisation pour le la mise
la prise de leurs baux locatifs à
l'ensemble du parc locatif d'entreprise
immobilier d'entreprise trouvent
preneurs on voit souvent des pancartes
avec marc est allouée bureaux
d'entreprise vous devez pas forcément
apprécié de voir ces panneaux la
bacchante quand ils sont parés à la
panne au format so c'est plutôt une
bonne chose ça veut dire que c'est un
territoire comme qui tourne et qui
dynamique
globalement la vacance immobilière sur
saint-quentin elle est de 7 7 à 8% 7 et
8%
si on compare par rapport au reste du
département ou cesser la moyenne
nationale
c'est pas mal puisque ça permet d'avoir
un peu fluidité bien sûr on travaille à
ne pas en avoir trop
il y en avait d'ailleurs un peu plus il
ya quelques années il ya trois quatre
ans on était à presque 10 %
donc il ya des opérations de
renouvellement démolition reconstruction
qui ont été menées il ya des très belles
arrivées comme safran qui va utiliser 42
min carrés sur un site qui était vide
depuis quelques années donc on a aussi
heureusement des entreprises qui
occupent des bâtiments disponibles
aujourd'hui qui font que cette vacance
n'est pas trop élevée et qu'elle permet
au contraire une rotation est d'avoir
toujours une offre une disponibilité
dans tout ça vous inquiète pas nous
inquiète nos gardes et non encordés des
bureaux des bureaux vides comment vous
intervenez avec l'agglomération de saint
quentin pour les convaincre ces groupes
notamment safran par exemple bas sont
heureux qui ont la main sur tout et qui
décide où au final vous avez quand même
des arguments des cartes à jouer
des entreprises comme safran si elle
arrive c'est parfois qu'elles sont déjà
un petit peu là safran était déjà un
petit peu là à travers snecma qui était
la structure industrielle d'innovation
des moteurs
donc il ya déjà parfois une histoire une
entreprise qui dont une filiale est déjà
là
il ya des filières un peu d'excellence
sur territoire et ses filières celeron
nautique l'automobile la santé
la construction donc ces filières elle
crée un écosystème et elles attirent des
entreprises de ceux de la filière et
c'est cette dynamique autour des
filières que chargé moi tout
particulièrement au sein de la direction
du développement économique de la
communauté d'agglomération de conduire
d'accompagner de faire vivre et de est
de faire en sorte que ces entreprises
qui sont la face à savoir que l travail
venir satisfaisante avec le territoire
et que elles sont susceptibles de te
faire venir par des partenariats
d'autres entreprises pour ceux qui sont
faites pas familier un petit peu toutes
les ficelles que vous pouvez utiliser
concrètement vous leur dites quoi elle
est venue à saint quentin en yvelines
parce que les routes sont plus sympas il
ya plus de logement c'était une
agglomération verte et bleue on leur dit
un peu tout ça oui que les salariés
aussi seront bien accueillis c'est ce
qui est important pour une entreprise
c'est pouvoir loger ses salariés aux
loyers moins chers
la dimension de l'allemand les logements
les services aux entreprises les
services aux salariés tout cet
écosystème sur saint quentin qui
maintenant une certaine valeur et qui à
l'état qu'un service civique qui sont
perçues par l'agglomération par exemple
faurecia s'est implanté donc là aussi
c'est un levier à actionner pas de
concurrencer alors les taxes sont
principalement nationale sur le sueur
sur l'immobilier d'entreprise
les taxes sur les bureaux là on vend une
hausse des taxes qui sont à l'échelle
nationale met donc le levier sur les
taxes et pas et pas considérable le
levier il et il est plutôt sûr
l'accueil des entreprises sur le
territoire le faire valoir ce territoire
auprès des entreprises et auprès de
celles qui voudraient venir pour leur
raconter un peu ce territoire ce
qu'elles vont y trouver quel est
l'intérêt pour elles de d'intégrer cet
écosystème renaud boyoud crédit agricole
airbus sodexo quelques-uns des grands
groupes qui font partie de cet
écosystème justement d'autres groupes
vont arriver à safran va arriver
baxter laboratoire américain
pharmaceutique va arriver par exemple en
cas notamment à maurepas oui c'est ça le
très bon de 50 ans il ya effectivement
un phénomène aussi de concentration de
sur des pôles qui sont maintenant très
d'identifier vous avez parlé de vélizy
et saint quentin en yvelines sur des
études c'est vrai que c'est d'opposer
très très identifié des entreprises des
investisseurs en immobilier qui met donc
à disposition au cours ou qui rénovent
aussi leur immobilier et on accompagne
cette rénovation sur le territoire pour
faire en sorte que l'offre immobilière
reste toujours au niveau voire se
régénère et redevienne une offre
d'oeuvres d'une concurrence entre
bénézis par exemple être un contenu mais
oui elle concurrence mais plutôt celle
ci c'est complémentaire vous êtes
forcément aussi une dernière question
tributaires du marché financier parce
que les entreprises se développent pas
forcément en période de crise ça se
ressent dans les chiffres il ya des
inquiétudes à avoir
bien sûr il ya des inquiétudes à voir en
ce moment faut être particulièrement
vigilant faut faire le maximum pour les
entreprises
maintenant le levier des territoires
c'est ce que je veux dire on n'a pas
tous les leviers de l'économie par
canton à travers l'offre du territoire
et la dynamique d'un territoire en
incapacité à faire prendre un choix
d'une entreprise qui va s'installer un
endroit up ou à un autre et puis les
entreprises ont besoin de temps en temps
d'arbitrer sur leur localisation
et en ce moment il ya beaucoup aussi
d'arbitrage sur les repositionnements
l'optimisation aussi de le meux de leur
mobilier pour une entreprise le
l'immobilier c'est le 2e poste après
après la masse salariale donc c'est
quelque chose quand même d'importants
que que les entreprises regardent de
près les niveaux locatif est le rapport
entre le niveau locatif et la qualité du
territoire sur 50 ans on se débrouille
pas trop mal entre le montre la synergie
entre ces deux paramètres et là ce sera
votre conclusion merci thierry cazes
d'être venu nous parler ce soir donc de
l'immobilier d'entreprise pour avoir
apporté ces différentes précision pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas forcément
toutes les ficelles et tous les enjeux
qui se trouve derrière merci à vous on
va changer d'univers pour la fin de ce
journal loisirs enchaînement de figures
samedi dernier à magny les hameaux du
boardslide o3sis flip une compétition de
skateboard
je pense que le sentiment de me
connaître ou le spectacle était de mise
découverte de la discipline en tout cas
avec claire cambier qui paraît plus
calés que moi et c'est parti pour deux
minutes de show l'enjeu pour françois
réalisé la meilleure performance pour se
qualifier en finale samedi dernier à
magny les hameaux
l'association les enfants de sky
organisé une compétition de skateboard
parmi les critères le style la
technicité la nature des figures les
tricks et la rapidité d'exécution
françois ne s'en est pas trop mal tiré
sa botte secrète l'improvisation
seulement je suis allé à un peu au cello
koussa waldner en fait pas de pression
comme ça pour pimenter les choses les
goûts filles affrontent regular entendez
par là pied droit devant contre pied
gauche
dans le camp opposé on compte sarah la
seule fille de la compétition je veux
dire que les gauchistes aux meilleurs
jeux chez go comme messi n'ont à vrai
dire on n'en faut pas qu'il ya vraiment
de différence comme le skate parc a été
aménagé autant pour les goûts fait que
les regular dont finalement c'est pas
aussi bien quand on est là aux autres si
finalement les regular qui finit sur le
podium françois est le grand gagnant à
la seconde place georges la catégorie
moins de 18 ans permettait aux plus
jeunes d'avoir leur chance mais cet
événement était surtout le moyen de
valoriser le lieu est de réunir des
passionnés de toute la france avec le
petit espoir de développer l'activité
dans les environs si l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines pomme de
débloquer des fonds pour faire un skate
park l'an pourra faire quelque chose de
plus grand voilà je pense notamment aux
six au vélodrome qui a ouvert ses portes
et donc c'est dommage qu'on puisse pas
avoir quelque chose de fermé et quelque
chose qui pourrait apporter encore plus
de monde quelque chose de couverts donc
avec un aspect aussi sécurité pour les
personnes les enfants discale envisage à
terme de proposer à jean genet terre
merci de nous avoir suivi le journal
revient demain mercredi mêmes horaires
excellente soirée sur tv fil 78
il